eighth grade i told him i was gonna be a
macdonald's all-american i told him i
was gonna you know go to kentucky and
try to go to the nba i screened from
richards maxing in
traffic gets it to go what a shot from
maxi
tyrese maxi first bucket of the game he
does it with the left next
gets the wildcats
[Music]
so my alarm clock goes off at 4 50 every
single morning
most of the time my uncle throw
something together a little breakfast
sandwich and then we're getting to the
gym about 5 45
stretch start working out at six as soon
as the workout's done at around 7
15 7 20. heading to the weight room
morning
good morning how are you go get a good
lift in at about eight o'clock over
there at sports rehab
finish the lift around nine o'clock now
i'm coming back at 10. it's my third
workout today and people haven't even
got woken up yet
that's just a psychological advantage
that i think i have over some players
now you're looking to get your drag
action for three okay
ready come get it all right
normally the pre-drive process is a
little bit faster it's about
two months so whenever you take a time
frame like we've experienced in the
pandemic
it has allowed for the people that
really wanted to put in the time
to get better you know it's been
different because of covet for sure
not what i expected and i went you know
i envisioned in my mind
but i mean it happens you know you have
to adapt to the situation i like to keep
my head down and grind
so i got to focus extremely hard on my
grind and just working out and
spending extra time with family and
friends it's just been embracing the
embracing the situation
circumstances i'm just been grinding
it's just it's honestly kind of worked
out because it's helped him
just stay in the gym more and that's it
i mean that's pretty much all he wants
to do anyways work out
when first got out here my entire
friends was out here my mom my dad
my sisters grandmother and we were all
out here together
so but now it's just me and him so
that's crazy that's like you can tell
how long we've been here we got here
before summer started and we're still
here
when we in the whole new season we fall
now so like it's just crazy but i mean
it's been cool man just been
keeping my head a little grounded
starting at six every single morning you
know since may 23rd so
so our goal every day for tyreese is to
make over 2 000
shots so if you look at 2000 times six
that's what 12 000 shots a week over a
five
six month period that's a lot of shots
and that's made shots
so it wasn't complex it was super simple
this is what we have to correct let's
put in the work it's been great working
out with chris uh
i really appreciate them because um when
i first got out here they set my
schedule for 10 o'clock
and i told him i was like he calls the
gym the barber shop
and i told him i want to be the first
one in the shop first one to chair every
single day
until i'm gone and he said okay fine
we're gonna get here at six
5 45 5 a.m is not for
everybody not only basketball players
but people
are of products of what we do every day
like daily routine it's like brushing
your teeth it's like tying your shoes
you don't think about it you just do it
over and over again
and that's what basketball is it's about
creating
a routine that you can continue to build
on top of
[Applause]
tyrese gets the waking up early for my
mom
and his other grandmom they wake up 5 15
5 30 every morning from working out two
three times a day
watching film with his dad after games
um
watching just regular games whether it's
nba or college it just seems like
it's basketball basketball basketball so
in second grade my dad he asked me who
my favorite player was
and i told him dwyane wade and his
response to that was uh if you want to
be like dwyane wade
you have to put time in in the gym it's
not all about when you go to practice
and when you play in the game you got to
put in
after hours you got to put in extra
hours of work and um
outwork people and ever since that day
you know it kind of clicked in my mind
like okay fine if that
if that's what it takes to be great and
that's what i'm going to do i don't want
to have any
what ifs or dang i wish i could have i
want to be able to say i laid it all
out on the line and i maximized my
potential and got one percent better
every single day
maxing the other way with the spin move
oh
they love it you know there's a major
difference between
being a really elite pro
and being a collegiate basketball player
and that separation
is in the brain so when you watch these
great players play
they can dominate the game from a mental
standpoint
they're that much better than you
because of the brain and we call it
planet from the neck up
my thing is if you put the work in like
i put so much time in the gym these 6 am
workouts these
after practice shooting and before game
shooting
i have so much confidence in myself so
every time i step on a court you know i
know what i can do
and people ask me you know i made
certain shots like did you know you can
make those i'm like
man i work on those shots every single
day it wasn't nothing new to me maxie
knocks one down what a big answer
a huge answer by kyrie's maximum tyrese
is a winning player first of all he's
he's a terrific basketball player
and kind of like i've said about jamal
and tyler and shea and you know you're
gonna
regret not taking this kid he falls in
the same mode of
he has all kind of ways to score the
basketball
i mean those kind of kids have that
spirit about him so
i have a lot of faith in wherever he
goes
they will call me and say wow we are so
happy
that we took him what up i'm just
thinking of you
you're on the camera so don't be talking
crazy out here talking crazy now
you know you you know you i wouldn't say
anything
no not at all how are you today son
that ain't that ain't real that was fake
yes we're super excited i can't wait
um i don't know i'm excited and i guess
excited and nervous and happy and elated
all in one emotion
that's the scary part right you know
what's going to happen
what number is it going to go where is
it going to go where is it going to live
what is it going to feel like all of
that all in one
emotion i think because same thing every
parent feels
right yeah i guess you're right man i
can't speak for everyone else on the
amount of work that was put in
but he's not only ready to be drafted
he's ready to contribute
so i'm very interested in looking at
what the draft class looks like this
year for him
no summer league you know this is going
to be a new season for everybody
every kid has that goal of becoming a
professional athlete but to actually
know somebody or to be
related to somebody that's close to
somebody and you actually see the whole
process
play out it's going to be crazy and it's
going to be a
great time not many people can say that
they did
exactly what they wanted to do with
their life so and i was blessed and the
lord blessed me to be able to play
basketball
i really appreciate chris and it's just
amazing to have people in your corner
not just him my dad's been here my mom
my sister my grandmother
my nieces everybody's been here you know
they all support me and it's been an
amazing time and i can't wait for the
future